ariana grande is reportedly returning to  Manchester England as soon as next week  the 23 year old singer penned an  emotional letter to fans on Friday  revealing her plans to return to the  brave city where 22 died and 59 were  left injured in a terrorist attack  outside of her concert last week  according to TMZ Ariana will be heading  back to Manchester much sooner than  anticipated and is planning to headline  a star-studded benefit concert in the  victims honour just two weeks after the  deadly attack ariana is said to be  reaching out to some of the biggest  names in music to participate and the  concert will be held at one of the four  big arenas in the city all of the  proceeds will go to the victims and  their families